Die Uhr tickt und die Zeit für “Opportunity”
läuft ab.
Seit dem heftigen Staubsturm im Sommer 2018
hat die NASA keinen Kontakt mehr zu ihrem
Marsrover.
Alle bisherigen Wiederbelebungs-Versuche sind
gescheitert.
Jetzt startet das NASA-Ingenieurteam einen
letzten Rettungsversuch.
Wie die Chancen für “Opportunity” wirklich
stehen und welche Tricks die NASA jetzt noch
auf Lager hat, i Clixoom Science & Fiction
- hier gibt es täglich neue faszinierende
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. - herzlich willkommen!
Das war wirklich ein Drama!.
Wochenlang tobte im Sommer 2018 ein heftiger
Sandsturm auf dem Mars - laut NASA ein “planetenumfassendes
Staubereignis”.
Mitte Juni dann die Horrormeldung.
Die NASA musste mitteilen, dass sie den Kontakt
zu ihrem Rover “Opportunity” verloren
hatte.
Die Vermutung: Der feine Staub hatte höchstwahrscheinlich
die Paneele des Rovers bedeckt und somit die
Elektronik gestört.
Zudem blockte der Sturm wohl das Sonnenlicht
ab, das die Solarzellen von “Opportunity”
zur Energiegewinnung benötigen.
Die Akkuladung war letztendlich soweit gefallen,
dass sich der Rover selbstständig in einen
“Ruhemodus” versetzt hatte.
Tatsächlich eine ziemliche Tragödie, denn
der Marsrover ist der dienstälteste und damit
zuverlässigste und fährt seit 15 Jahren
über die Marsoberfläche.
Und genau deswegen lässt die NASA seitdem
nicht locker, um “Opportunity” doch noch
wiederzubeleben.
Dazu John Callas; er ist NASA-Projektmanager:
“Auch wenn wir bisher von ihm keine Antwort
erhalten haben und die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das noch mal der Fall ist, von Tag zu
Tag geringer wird, werden wir weiterhin jede
logische Möglichkeit nutzen, um wieder Kontakt
aufzunehmen.”
Mittlerweile sind es laut NASA-Website mehr
als 800 Wiederherstellungsbefehle, die an
den Rover gesendet wurden.
Jetzt startet die NASA einen letzten Versuch,
“Opportunity” wieder zu reaktivieren.
Konkret werden dazu neue Befehle genutzt,
die die bislang eingesetzten Kommandos ergänzen.
Mögliche Fehlfunktionen sollen dadurch behoben
werden.
Eines der insgesamt drei Kommandos befiehlt
dem Rover, seine Borduhr neu einzustellen
und auf das Ersatzmodul zu wechseln.
Der zweite Befehl bezieht auf das zweite der
drei möglichen Szenarien: nämlich, dass
das sogenannte X-Band, also die primäre Funkverbindung,
nicht mehr funktioniert.
Das letzte mögliche Szenario besteht daraus,
dass sowohl das primäre als auch das sekundäre
Radiomodul ausgefallen sein könnten.
Doch läuft der Rettungsmannschaft der NASA
die Zeit weg.
Das große Problem ist der Südwinter auf
dem Mars, der bald ansteht.
Die damit verbundene Kälte und der Frost
könnten Teile des Rovers zerstören.
Nicht nur die Computersysteme, sondern auch
die Leitungen und die Batterien könnten irreparabel
beschädigt werden.
Dazu Steven Squyres von der Cornell University:
“Das Ende der Windsaison könnte daher das
Ende für den Rover bedeuten.
Uns läuft die Zeit davon.”
Aktuell spielt der Wind auf dem Mars der NASA
aber noch in die Hände, denn im besten Fall
könnte diese sogenannte “Staubbeseitigungs-Jahreszeit”
dafür sorgen, dass Sand und Staub von den
Solarpaneelen des Rovers geweht werden.
Darauf hatte nicht nur die NASA große Hoffnungen
gesetzt.
Bislang ist dies jedoch nicht passiert, was
dafür spricht, dass die Funkstille nicht
unbedingt am Staub auf den Sonnensegeln und
dem Energiemangel begründet ist.
Denkbar ist zudem nämlich auch, dass die
Funkstille an einem Ausfall der internen Uhr
oder des Funksystems liegen könnte.
Dem Rover droht somit im schlimmsten Fall
dasselbe Schicksal wie dem Rover “Spirit”,
der 2010 auf dem Mars eingefroren war.
Doch egal, wie es jetzt mit “Opportunity”
weitergeht: Er wird eines der erfolgreichsten
Projekte der Planetenforschung bleiben.
Denn “Opportunity” ist tatsächlich schon
seit Ende Januar 2004 auf dem Roten Planeten
unterwegs und hat die Ziele seiner Entwickler
damit längst übertroffen.
Ursprünglich war geplant, dass er lediglich
90 Tage lang den Planeten erkunden soll.
Interessanter Fakt: Mittlerweile hat er in
den 14 Jahren schon rund 45 Kilometer zurückgelegt
- mehr also die Streckenlänge eines Marathons.
Und die fünf spannendsten Fakten über die
Milchstraße gibt es als Videopremiere auf
dem englischen Clisoomkanal: The five most
exiting facts about the Milky Ways.
Dafür hier klicken.
Sehr sehr spannend.
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!